initially exactly you a man is not not  going to find you attractive and then  think oh because you you can cook well  it's got a chef a man's gonna find you  attractive let's ask Andrew  be with a girl that's five out of ten  because she can cook  is that what I said oh firstly that's  not what she said to be fair and the  secondly I'd be with a 10 out of 10 who  can cook because I'm top jeep but to  make the point I think what you have to  understand is what men are looking for  in a relationship so you did the the  street interview and you're asking  single people probably young people  probably idiots you know they're on  camera talking [ __ ] about good head all  this garbage that's [ __ ] what men  are interested in in life not just in  their relationship but in their life as  a whole is status I don't think most  people understand especially women how  competitive the male world is and how  competitive it is for status